[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to cbs this morning these
people in the u.s and around the world
are standing in solidarity with ukraine
a different kind of global resistance is
damaging russia's economy leading many
russians to line up at their banks to
get their money out the u.s and its
european allies have agreed to keep
those banks out of a financial messaging
system called swift hoping to put more
pressure on russia's government
also the treasury department has just
imposed a new sanction to stop the
russian government's central bank from
reaching any of its assets it has here
in this country cbs news business
analyst jill slessinger is here to
explain the importance of swift good
morning to you joe i'm so glad you're
here because i had never even heard of
swift until this weekend you are not
alone good morning well swift is the
secure messaging system that underpins
the movement of money across borders
while swift is not a payment system it's
how banks make transfer requests to one
another and it has become essential in
the global economy handling millions of
daily requests so when russia exports
natural gas to europe payment requests
for that transaction are made through
swift and when western banks are owed
money from russian-based entities they
too would use swift
excluding russian banks from swift could
make it difficult if not impossible for
russian companies to get paid for goods
and services though it remains unclear
if the swift measures will impact energy
products at this time but these measures
they essentially isolate the world's
12th largest economy ordinary russian
citizens will not be able to buy
products like iphones from the us cheese
from france luxury goods from italy and
for those who invest the russian stock
market has lost a third of its value
over the past week critically russia's
expulsion from swift will also mean that
russians are cut off financially from
their families who live abroad so tony
this is a big move among the
international community it is a big move
and if you've got rubles this morning
you're not feeling too good financially
thank you very much jill